speaking of who calls drag race she made
us laugh she made us cry
and she served some stunting looks on
this season 13 of rupaul's drag race
but this weekend fans were shocked when
she took her final bow
she was too sashayed away let's take a
quick look
back at her very first moment entering
the work room
let me break the ice i'm denali and i
am chicago's ice queen so i am
icy spicy and a little bit dicey
first one is winners coming first a
fight of drag
i'm a professional ice skater i am drags
gold medal
and i might not have made it to the
olympics in figure skating but i did
make it to the olympics in drag
oh please welcome it is the fabulous
denali
hi everybody denali it is so good to see
you know full disclosure i am a judge on
rupaul's drag race
and uh i have to say i was even shocked
to see you leave
how did you feel you know it was very
bittersweet
i am that olympic girl i have the
mindset and the goal to make it to the
top four
but anything can happen on drag race and
if you have one bad day
it can be out for you so i am really
excited to ask you
because your looks are so extraordinary
wow but
do you have some quick tips to share
with us
for makeup i'm a beauty junkie and
i'm always looking for like a hot tip do
you have any
absolutely you know drag queens we
always try to kind of like over
emphasize things in order to kind of
hide some other things you know
compensate for some
maybe masculine features you know what
i'm saying um and one way that i found a
trick especially with my
lips it's a very classic drag queen trip
to create dimension
whatever base color that you're using if
you go in with white
or any like white cream right in the
center of your lip you can see there's
just a little bit right there for me
um it'll add a lot of dimension to your
lip and create it full looking kind of
plump lip
so i always go in with a little white in
the center you know what i'm saying okay
see that is what i'm talking about we
thank you denali ask the drag queen and
it's not i have to say you know millions
of viewers all over the world fell in
love with you and it wasn't just for
your look it was for your heart so i
just want to say
thank you for really bringing it this
season denali
thank you so much ross and
congratulations on your engagement as
well oh what
thank you no way
[Music]
and i will get in trouble if i don't
tell you denali that my daughter olive
loves you and she's such a big fan of
the show she's seen every season and we
just wish you the very best and
hopefully you'll come back and visit us
absolutely thank you drew barrymore and
hi olive oh my god
oh thank you my stock just rose
[Music]
you